How do you personally
move through things like
burnout or life
fucking you over
as you're just trying to
do your job?
It's okay if it takes
some of you guys
longer to get certain places
than others.
I know people that had
slower starts than others
that are super successful today.
I know people that have
had crazy hot starts
and then burnt out
really fast and needed breaks.
Everyone's pace is different.
Don't benchmark yourself
against other people
all the time.
You will always feel inadequate.
You'll always feel like
you're burning out because
like there's always someone
who's better in some
aspect or another.
It doesn't matter whether
you're a billionaire.
you're on a minimum wage job,
whether you're starting your career,
whether you're in the C-suite.
You got to be comfortable
like being yourself
and understanding like
as long as I'm doing
the best of my ability,
I don't have to follow
the path that someone else
has set for themselves.